yeah hello welcome to new video in the a
45 repertoire serious this video will
deal with move some other than to Knight
f3 Knight c3 Bishop c4 F for this we've
already covered our we'll cover in the
next videos um so what we need to look
at here is mostly the move to deform
oops
deform and this introduces either some
gambit continuation or an opening called
the center game a white recaptures on d4
with the Queen um maybe let's first
start with the other tries here for
white there are some really rarely
played moves one is Knight f3 which can
easily transpose into another opening I
just recommend here to play 96 to
transpose to to the scotch game you need
to know this anyway so you can easily
transpose here if you want to try to
punish white for this somewhat obscure
move order you could also consider this
Bishop check here which could win a pawn
basically as moves other than c3 don't
make much sense here so wide usually go
c3 and you get an extra pawn iam this is
quite similar to a line that might arise
after c3 where black captures the pawn
and here you should be for can easily
transposed to this kind of setup I shown
before but my simple approach here on
Knight f3 is to just plain @ c6 the
transposed to the scotch I simply don't
like to bother with additional lines and
I honestly don't like to take the pawn
anyway so just 96 and you've got another
opening another idea here for white is
Bishop c4
which you can just answer will answer
with an ID f 6 and this I've shown
briefly and in the video 3 of the series
I think where this position was
occurring here and it's it's a
transposition I shown this briefly e5 d5
or Knight f3 should be 4 check ok so
this also could happen but usually what
we captures here or place III this which
is reham is a really am
engine tin uation a typical gambit style
approach black here has two main options
or two options I don't think there's a
decent third move black can't capture on
please c3 after which white usually just
recaptures or even sacrifices or tries
to sacrifice even more
I think theoretically and this
continuation is is fine for black you
can take this pawn and defend the
position with with this extra material
but I don't like to in general like to
give white some initiative for a pawn so
I just played the 5 p.m. which is I
think also still the main move instead
of taking after d5 y doesn't have much
choice he needs to capture on d5 he
doesn't have any other move basically
sometimes people even played in five
here in speed games but you can just
take the pawn and you're just a simple
pawn up and have also a nice central
control this is just next report for
nothing here you can even have a choice
to just defend
t5 or advance black is just a pawn up
why does it have any chances to to
attack him so he takes d5 is my father
main move after which black just
recaptures with the Queen and here white
needs to get to spawn back after which
black develops knight c6 and also at XD
form as you can see this approach leads
to very quick development from black so
you have no issues whatsoever with
getting your pieces to active positions
both bishops are already open and wide
also has got this isolated pawn here so
you've got some natural target now white
plays Knight e3 which is I think by far
the main line
if white defense before in another way
maybe we should be three you just
continue with quick development like the
check here Knight c3 Knight f6 of course
you can move the Queen later right now
the pin saves this piece let's say like
this and black just has a fine position
here you've got everything nicely on
active positions you can just cancel
next move or even try to increase the
pressure on c3 this bishop might go to
g4 or to e6 helping to locate the pawn
so black is just fine you don't need to
know any specific lines just develop
your pieces drafting active squares on
idea three young black plays Bishop g4
and reduce the threat on the d4 pawn
like capturing on f3 and then capturing
on D form and now white usually goes
Bishop e2 you can also play Knight c3
but just not C 3 after which black plays
this and usually and transposes to the
line I'm about to show so there's not
much difference we should be too and now
the check here of course black cannot
immediately
oops immediately with material here
because of this check here and you lose
the Queen so it's not that easy so the
check is is just just good here so now
white goes not c3 which is the most
natural move on other moves you can just
simply continue development let's say he
goes do this
it could just take let's say Queen takes
Knight f6 I just develop your pieces to
active positions black has no problems
at all here he might even consider to
take here and give this check on a6 to
this to somewhat distort whites whites
plane and Bishop d2 is really a
continuation everybody plays Knight c3
here is the most natural move and now
our black needs to know one specific
maneuver here and this is to take on f3
Bishop takes and of course you still
cannot take on deform because of the
bishop c6 check but you have Queen c4
and this is important to remember this
maneuver here prevents white from
canceling and this is really a huge
issue white cannot get his King out of
the center so he needs to really do some
drastic measures here to to get his King
out and usually why it takes on c6 he
doesn't have much choice what white
could try as Queen b3 also this has the
idea of black captures on d4 that white
could really cancel so you don't want to
help him this way but black can just
take on v3 and continue developing and
now you see that white has a really
damaged pawn structure here this double
pawns and still the isolated pawn on d4
so black is fine here
maybe it's still around equal if white
plays play some on in a in a very exact
fashion but this kind of position has
got the tendency to be already quite
good for black what needs to prove that
his structural weaknesses are not a huge
issue so in this position white usually
takes on c6 and now we have a choice
between a safe move and a somewhat risky
move the safe move which I also
recommend is to take with the porn this
keeps the Queen's position on C for life
and still prevents castling but you can
also capture with the Queen but this is
somewhat somewhat risk this is this is
somewhat more risky sorry I just got a
call on skype it this is this is more
risky and the problem is that white now
can castle and has chances for for
active play with d5 you have some
development issues and so I recommend to
take with the pawn it's just a simpler
solution so now Queen e2 check while
still has this castling issue so he
needs to get rid of the Queen and now
just 97 yeah we've transposed into sort
of yeah it's it's almost an endgame
you've got Queens off and two minor
pieces exchanged and this endgame is
around equal I think if Y plays exactly
it is equal so this position is is
playable also for win as black because
white still has this somewhat weak pawn
on d4 not so the whole structure has a
bit of the tendency to leave wide with
the bad bishop as the force on a black
squared F 2 and B 2 also it sometimes
to tonight and gameplay for black I
think this position is nothing to be
afraid of also you need to keep in mind
that white initially try to yeah to play
a gambit to get quick attack going maybe
on your King and play your aggressive
attacking chess and okay this is just
over now we need to play some rather dry
position and this is most likely not to
its liking I have really good
experiences with this position against
attacking players they're sometimes
really helpless in this endgame
positions if you prefer somewhat more
complicated position of course you can
also try this Queen c6 move but this is
risky really I tried this a couple of
times and in blitz games and without
ever having really analyzed it and I
really got some problems so it's not so
easy to play in comparison to me take c6
which is just just easy for black you've
got no problems at all so this gambit
continuation really is nothing to be
afraid of what you need to know is so
only to be well let's say you have this
move honor white can easily play this
here with the knight moves inserted and
this is just the same so if you've got a
weapon against this second d4 and then
c3 you also have something against this
is just a simple transposition okay so
this is the the gambit continuation c3
now to Queen takes d4 this is some most
most often caught the center game yet
somewhat somewhat weird-looking system
because white brings out his Queen early
but it's yeah it needs to be taken no
seriously it's not completely completely
stupid continuation
black plays 96 which is very natural
move of course just taking the Queen and
white needs to move it and usually goes
to e3 here the idea to to go to e3 is
connected with preventing black from
playing d5 if what is looking for
another square he sometimes goes queenie
form after this some yeah you have a
huge choice you can just develop them
with normal moves like Bishop c5 Knight
f6 there's nothing special to to know
here I reflect at a move with chances I
think not being played before I just
really played the check here which I
which I quite like
I'm busy - you've got Queen e7 which is
already very nice from black if I was
just hanging and it's not so easy to to
protect it so c3 and then Bishop c5
provoking c3 also pretty much prevents
white from long cancelling if he wants
to cancel long it usually wants to put
the knight on c3 and this is not
possible now just normal development
should be should be very very fine for
black okay so Queen a for that is an
alternative but Queen e3 is by far the
main move non + f6 just developing and
here white usually continues Knight c3
and generally sad years to play Knight
c3 Bishop d2 and long castle quickly
cancel long here white has some minor
alternatives one is oops not this main
move Bishop d2 after this black has a
choice he can just play they should be
four after which wider simply doesn't
have anything else than Knight c3 with
just transposes you could also think
about Bishop e7 - to play d5 the next
move is also sign for black
so mr. P 2 is not dangerous sometimes
why place the somewhat strange movie 5
attacking the 5 night there they have 6
9 immediately but this can be punished
really 94 Queeny for white needs to move
the Queen again and now I White's idea
is that this move supposed to be an
error a mistake because of their form
but the fun thing is black actually can
take it form the sunset with d5 let's
say Queen e3d for Queen to e2 and then
there should be 6 the point is that F
takes e5 like just castles and has a
huge attack really this is this is a
terrible position for white if he
captures on d6 black can go rook e8
winner winning the Queen so he cannot
take so Knight f3 and then rupee 8 and
black will open up the e-file you don't
do any - to memorize this just keep in
mind if someone really a ghost with this
sacrifice piece here and then quickly
develop your your pieces and attack the
King in the middle black has two points
for the piece already and the huge
attack if you if you analyze this
position with the computer it instantly
shows a pretty pretty clear black
advantage so you just need to have the
guts to to do this Queen e2 is another
possibility there Black has got Bishop
g4 Knight f3 Bishop c5 which is pretty
similar on F takes e5 now black even has
herbs moves like this year and and it's
can create terrible let's say h3 another
possibility
castles F takes e5 Knight takes e5 Queen
e5 rook e8 the Queen again and this is
yeah two pawns for peace at the huge
attack Black has got everything
developed castle already Queen h4 coming
up and rooks in the the center terrible
position this is not defensible I think
so if I this is just a gamble where
black needs to know his stuff um if you
somehow don't dare to play this which I
which would be a shame because just just
nice there's also an alternative here in
d5 it takes d5 Bishop e6 which is also
fine for black but you could you should
really a sec the piece that's it's a
brilliant brilliant attack you you will
get okay it's very rare that white plays
d5 okay that's e3 is the main move after
which she go Bishop before just the most
active way to deploy the Bishop Bishop
d2 castles long castle anamur p8 and as
you can see an a black has a good
development only he's not playing at the
solution on c8 but everything else is
nicely developed and now white usually
goes Queen g3 which is understandable
because the e4 pawn is under constant
pressure and black was threatening d5 so
he moves the Queen away other moves are
also fine for black let's say f3 you
will already have t5 threatening deform
and putting huge pressure on the center
so f3 is no good move Bishop c4 has a
possibility
after which black has more than one good
move but a simple continuation is
something like this t6f 395 winning a
tempo
and then a5 with the idea of going a4
next move on let's say Bishop takes c3
and then a4 and the bishop is in trouble
on b3 Blake just has a nice position you
can also go Bishop e6 to to exchange
this bishop so I'm not much to fee again
so Quincy's Queen g3 is the main move
yeah after this that's just one thing
you need to know the four pawn of course
is under under huge pressure and what
you really should do is you should take
it if you play any passive moves here
like d6 or I don't know you should f8 or
something white will have a nice
attacking position you simply need to
take you form the fun thing is that you
have two ways to take it
there's rook takes e4 or Knight takes d4
and both moves are probably fine for
black and what you do is yeah just a
matter of choice what you need to be
aware of it will be a tactical yeah
a tactical fight there you know you need
to really calculate a very sharp and
concrete variations as you grab this
pawn and try to get away with it you
have the best chances to do so for
instance and if you if you check this
with the computer he just says that
black is yeah more or less
clearly better but it would be a
tactical fight your net to spirit look
briefly at the tools the first move is
of course Knight takes e4 the simpleness
white needs to take rook takes and okay
your pawn up what does white have for
the pawn yeah well actually not so much
he's not not ahead in development but
what he what he will achieve is he will
most likely win at least one tempo on
the rook on e4 and he's got a somewhat
active Queen position on g3 I just show
a brief sample
line could try Bishop f4 here to check
the c7 pawn after which black guy was an
ID Queen to f6 and now a little trickier
and this position is full of little
tricks white cannot capture on c7 as
black plays d6 here now the bishop on c7
doesn't have a square so it needs to
capture or if he captures let's say if
he captures but he doesn't have a square
so he needs to capture sooner or later
then you got Queen h6 King me one we
should be 6 and we are black wins apiece
and this is checkmate yeah our next move
checkmate rook e1 still playable so on
this position he is full of little
technical tricks white cannot take so
right here let's 86 now black threatens
to check on h3 and f4 so what needs to
win a tempo here Knight g4 gaining a
nice active square for the knight King
b1 white cannot take here because of
this little trick so you see it's really
something very very calculation heavy
position on King b1 here black has a
nice shot 92 Queen a3 Bishop e3 very
nice move threatening made on b2 and
takes here check King c1
this one leads to checkmate I'm not I'm
not telling you actually it to learn
this variation we are move 60 I just
want to show briefly the kind of
technical stuff that might might arise
here okay
King C one takes check here and then
Bishop gh3 Bishop takes e4 we should
take g4 Naji - nice shot Queen takes
takes here 94 and Black is just winning
it's got seven points while it's got
four for some like here three pawns
before the exchange so and dominant
knight on e4 Black is just winning
instantly here this was just a simple
line to show the kind of yeah technical
struggles that might arise that's
something you need to be aware of if you
grab the pointed you should grab the
point everything else just bad you need
to be ready - two - two - fourth you
need to be ready for fist fight so to
say you have no way to to play this
opening in a in a solid and slow
somewhat a strategic fashion you need to
take the pawn and write it out and an
alternative here actually is to take on
e4 with the rook this is also possible
it's a similar but not quite the same
position that Yien the basic idea is of
course why takes here this just wins out
right and some SS simply too much
exchanged and like it's just a pawn up
for nothing it's a central pawn even so
white cannot take on e4 so you mostly
place a move like a three and then you
have even the funny move Bishop a5 yeah
and this is somewhat similar but of
course the Knights are still on the
knight on f6 and the knight on c3 and
but the type of position is quite
similar it's also very very technical
very technical position where I need to
calculate lines concretely I don't want
to go into much detail here I don't
think it's much used to to show long
lines in this variation this setup with
default in you for Queen e4 is rather
rare I never got it in the tournament
gamut even rally yet Blitzer at the time
controls but what you need to remember
this to to get to this position here and
then really grab the pawn it's no use to
to play d6 or any other passive move
then you will have a somewhat worse
position as White will develop with you
should see for F 3 H 4 and so on and you
will trying to really make you and you
have some chances to do so you need to
grab this point simply and and write it
out yeah this was the center game I
think really you don't need to study
much more in this opening it's just too
rare if you want to you can try to
analyze this position a bit maybe with
the computer to get some feel for other
tactical possibilities but well honestly
black is just better in this opening but
you need to be aware that it will be a
technical slugfest so to say this is one
of the very rare openings where yeah
white somewhat risky play yeah sort of
forces like to go into a technical fight
there's not much alternative here to to
grab it and and play on with the extra
pawn but yeah the need to calculate lots
of stuff yeah ok this was second deform
so let's quickly recap what we've done
so far in the first video or this is
video 2 of the series
shown what to do against the Kings
gambit the second video we had the
Bishop's game and the Vienna and this
video was about deform yeah are there
any other moves yeah well they are but I
don't think you need to have any
specific stuff prepared well for
instance I don't have anything else
prepared if white goes something else
actually a couple of weeks ago someone
played second c4 here against me and
after this you can just simply well
develop your pieces Knight f6 knight c6
very often against against irregular
setups you can you can you can set up
your pieces like this and then I have
six castles or maybe f5 even applied f5
in this game wasn't the Dutch league um
white can also play passive moves here
like d3 or something but of course you
don't need to study anything specific
here you can just develop normally
Bishop c5 Knight c6 Bishop c5 or you can
try to play c65 so you don't need to
know anything specific here these moves
are simply not aggressive enough to to
put much pressure on you white goes for
something like g3 for instance you have
always the option to develop normally
but again this even d5 might be an idea
as this leaves the rook hanging and this
can get can also can can get awkward
here this pin so other moves are really
you don't need to have anything special
prepared against against other moves
yeah okay we've done I've done three
videos now one on the King's gambit one
on bishops game we Anna one on d4 and
yeah briefly showing the other moves and
the upcoming videos will be about
yeah more mainstream more mainstream
lines after Knight f3 after Knight f3 I
think the next video will be about will
be about the four Knights and also about
the Pantheon II opening which is rare
but yeah it it might might be played
against you one time so you need to have
a little bit of something prepared okay
this will be the next video well thanks
for watching this video and yeah we'll
talk to you soon with the first lines
after Knight f3 thanks